scrolling through social media it's not
hard to find misinformation about covit
but it is harder to spot a lie from
someone in a position of trust your
doctor they could bring particular harm
to the public and to individuals it's
very hard to quantify how much harm that
they could produce a global news
investigation found a web of physicians
mostly in ontario and b.c have been
sharing unverified information about
vaccine side effects specifically blood
clots and heart inflammation some even
claimed the shots killed children others
were accused of issuing falsified
medical exemptions for masks and
vaccines all of the doctors except one
have an active medical license on
wednesday ontario's health minister
christine elliott urged the province's
college of physicians and surgeons the
cpso to crack down
including reviewing the licenses of
physicians found to be spreading
misinformation
the cpso says it is it confirmed there
are more than 40 physicians under
investigation for spreading
misinformation on covet 19 and seven
have had their licenses restricted or
suspended politics professor wayne
petrozzi says elliott's call to action
though is meaningless
there's a limit to
to to how much they have to listen to
you in bc the college of physicians and
surgeons has refused to release the
number of complaints it has received in
relation to the pandemic they need to
put in place a much more robust
framework of openness and transparency
with respect to
not only the the activities of the
associations but the decisions they make
health and law policy expert trudeau
lemons says historically these agencies
have not been proactive but notes
imposing too much government oversight
could also be problematic an excessive
level of policing that for example would
lead them to interfere
with normal debate within the medical
community a fine line experts agree
needs adjustment the status quo they say
leaves patients and the public
vulnerable jamie morocco global news
toronto